Next up, let's take a look at actions,
or those behaviors that result in
rewards and stem from
the triggers that you sent users.
Here, you'll want to optimize your
model to eliminate your user's pain and
get them to interact with your app,
thereby increasing their
potential to spend money.
Ask yourself the following questions.
Where is the most challenging
action in your product?
Why is it challenging?
How can you test and
improve this action?
Here's a hint.
Analytics play a huge role in finding
answers that are based on data.
Take a minute and jot down how you might
use analytics to help identify and
eliminate these roadblocks.